I'd like to show you an example of
supervised machine learning from my
robotics past, this robot you
see here is called Latgr or
learning applied to ground robotics.
It is using keeners neighbor
to learn how to navigate.
Let me talk a little bit about
what comes in and what goes out.
It has a sensor in front of it that
sees the world in front of it.
It can see along a number of
directions where there are obstacles or
where the road is clear.
So, the input is,
in which directions are their obstacles.
And also,
it has the direction towards the goal.
So in this case, the robots trying to
get to a goal that's off the left, but
these bushes that line the path are sort
of preventing it from getting there.
So x, in our case,
are these perceptions.
What do I see around me?
And what's the direction to the goal?
And y, or the output, Is,
which direction to steer.
So let's let it go for a while and
see how well it can navigate based on
a little bit of training
that it's been given.
It's doing pretty good here so far.
But, it hasn't been trained quite well
enough and boom, it goes off the path.
This is where learning comes in.
We back it up over that area
where it messed up, and
we switch the learning switch on,
and we're essentially tell it,
okay, watch what we do, that's
the correct thing to do in this case.
So it takes all those examples of x's
and y's, x's being the perception and
y being the way it should respond,
adds that to its memory, and
now when it's running live,
it consults this memory.
It says oh, I see this,
what should I do?.
It finds the k nearest neighbors to
that current observation and looks at
what they say, and they essentially vote
on what direction the robot should go.
Now after we've trained it for
about a half hour or
so, it's able to navigate through
difficult scenarios really quite easily.
So keep in mind, this robot's driving
autonomously, it's just consulting its
memory for when I saw this,
what was the right answer, why?
Supervised learning, and
it's able to get around quite well.
Here's another more
complicated scenario.
The goal where it's trying to get
is on the other side of that tree.
So that's supervised learning for
a robot and, again,
the model maps these perceptions x to y,
what it should do.
And finance instead of Y being
which way the robot should go,
it's often a prediction about
what a future price is.
Okay, enough about robots,
let's move on.